ich mache mir im Moment schwer Gedanken
um eine Gasrechnung wir haben erstmal
runter gedreht schon dick anziehen ja
die Unsicherheit ist ja vor allem das
große Thema und natürlich dass es
woraussichtlich halt einfach wahnsinnig
viel Geld kosten wird jeder dritte in
Deutschland ja mehr als jeder dritte
macht sich Sorgen die Gasrechnung nicht
mehr bezahlen zu können die Hälfte aller
Wohnungen wird hierzulande mit Gas
beheizt und das ist gerade doppelt so
teuer wie im vergangenen Jahr Experten
und Expertinnen befürchten dass wir uns
trotzdem staatlichen gaspreisbremse an
den sogenanntes neues normalgewöhnen
müssen also an einen Gaspreis für uns
Verbraucher der doppelt so hoch ist wie
vor dem russischen Angriffskrieg in
dieser Kontext Folge wollen wir klären
warum das so ist und damit herzlich
willkommen für die aktuelle hohen
Gaspreise gibt es im wesentlichen drei
Gründe und die schauen wir uns jetzt
etwas näher an erstens Russland liefert
nicht mehr Gas ist von nun an ein
knappes Gut zweitens die gestiegene
Gasnachfrage nach dem Ende der
corona-maßnahmen und drittens der Mangel
an kurzfristigen Alternativen blicken
wir also zuerst auf das dramatische Ende
der russischen Gasimporte die machten
bisher einen erheblichen Anteil unseres
gesamten
verbrauchsaussöl und Kohle zu setzen und
wir wollen jetzt so schnell wie möglich
davon wieder weg doch beim Gas ist das
etwas schwieriger
erstmals
Russland damit die Gaslieferungen nach
Deutschland über die Pipeline Nord
Stream 1 einzustellen nach der
Drosselung und später dem kompletten
Abschalten von Nord Stream 1 mussten die
ausbleibenden in Porto schnell und teuer
ersetzt werden wie aber konnte es zu
dieser fatalen Abhängigkeit überhaupt
erst kommen
vielen fällt dabei als erstes dieser
Mann ein Deutschland sichert in direkter
Partnerschaft mit Russland große Teile
seiner Energieversorgung auf Jahrzehnte
aber Nord Stream 1 ist nicht die Wurzel
allen Übels die energiepolitische
Abhängigkeit vom Kreml begann schon weit
vor Schröders Kanzlerschaft seinen
Anfang nahm das Projekt Erdgas aus
Russland zu beziehen
1969 über private Kontakte des damaligen
bayerischen Wirtschaftsministers Otto
Schädel in Wien
1970 wurde das Unternehmen zwischen der
Bundesrepublik und der UdSSR dann auf
höchster Ebene abgesegnet die
mineralölkrise hat nämlich alle
bisherigen Prognosen und Planungen
umgestoßen Gas ist nämlich gegenwärtig
relativ krisensicherer als Öl zu
beschaffen es ist eine Ironie der
Energiegeschichte als die arabischen
Ölstaaten Anfang 1973 eine embargo
verhängten stieg der Ölpreis um das
Vierfache die Bundesregierung die
seinerzeit zwei Drittel ihres Rohöls aus
den OPEC-Staaten importierte musste
ähnlich wie heute schnellen Ersatz
finden und die Hilfe die Deutschland
damals brauchte um sich aus der
Abhängigkeit der Ölstaaten zu befreien
die lieferte sie ahnenes die Sowjetunion
die Sowjet Fahne auch über weithaus in
Bayern hier wurde erstmalig eine
sowjetische Erdgaspipeline an das
westeuropäische verbunden ins
angeschlossen
und das Schicksal Richtung Abhängigkeit
nahm seinen Lauf 1980 unterzeichnete
Helmut Schmidt ein Abkommen zur Deutsch
sowjetischen Zusammenarbeit schon Ende
der 80er Jahre deckte die Sowjetunion
50% des Gasbedarfs der Bundesrepublik
2007 lag der Anteil der russischen Gases
zwischenzeitlich bei
43%, die Importe stiegen dann ab 2013
nach dem Start von Nord Stream 1 wieder
an
2018 erreichten die Lieferungen die
Marke von 55 % und das obwohl längst
klar war das Russland seine Energie
Lieferungen auch als Machtinstrument zu
nutzen wusste gegenüber der Ukraine hat
Russland immer wieder mit Lieferstopps
russland will die Ukraine als
Transitland diskreditieren und damit für
die Ostseepipeline werben die
umstrittene Ostseepipeline die er direkt
von Russland nach Deutschland führen
würde schon damals und das heutiger
Sicht sehr hellsichtig äußerten die
Ukraine und die baltischen Staaten
bedenken dass dadurch Russland ein
geopolitisches Druckmittel gegeben werde
viele der damals Beteiligten Namen es
mit nicht mehr als einem Schulterzucken
zu Erkenntnis zum anderen ist es so dass
wir natürlich auch auf Dauer von
russischen Erdgas Lieferungen abhängig
sein werden russland hat nun mal die
größten Gasreserven und das ist ein
Faktum und es gibt weit unsichere Länder
als Russland ist letzterer allerdings
hatte für Empörung gesorgt als er nur
zwei Monate nach seiner Kanzlerschaft
einen Posten im Aufsichtsrat des
russischen
Energieunternehmens gaspromannahme trotz
seiner traurig herausragenden Rolle in
Punkte Russland die Verantwortung für
die heutige Abhängigkeit von russischem
Gas teilt sich Gerhard Schröder mit
diversen Vorgängern und unter Angela
Merkel sollte sich die Abhängigkeit
sogar noch einmal intensivieren mit
Baubeginn der Pipeline Nord Stream 2 im
Jahr 2018 setzte sie verstärkt auf die
Energiekarte Russland unsere Meinung ist
das nostream 2 fertiggestellt werden
sollte aus heutiger Sicht wahrlich eine
Fehleinschätzung russland hat über
Jahrzehnte hinweg im Kalten Krieg in
allen Krisen zuverlässig Verträge
erfüllt und Gas geliefert das wurde
letzten Freitag hochoffiziell
aufgekündigt und damit sind wir beim
zweiten Grund fürs teure Gas der
unmittelbare nach Corona Boom die
Energiekosten steigen und schreien
allmählich zum Himmel wer sind schon
wieder beim Allzeithoch und die Bewegung
nach oben ist nach wie vor dynamisch die
rasche wenn auch nur relative Erholung
der Weltwirtschaft nach Ende der
corona-maßnahmen führte bereits vor dem
Krieg im Herbst 2021 zu deutlichen
Preissteigerungen es wird einfach viel
Gas nachgefragt weil die Weltkonjunktur
seit Abflauen der corona-pandemie wieder
anzieht und ein weiterer ist der letzte
lange Winter die Gasspeicher sind
einfach nicht mehr gut gefüllt während
der corona-krise hatte die Industrie
deutlich weniger Gas gebraucht als die
industrielle Produktion global und
gleichzeitig anzog stieg die Nachfrage
und damit auch der Preis der dritte
Grund für die hohen Preise ist der
Mangel an kurzfristigen Alternativen zum
russischen Gas und das beginnt schon bei
den Vorräten zur Überbrückung die hatte
Deutschland schlichtweg nicht im
ausreichenden Maß angelegt bisher gab es
dafür auch wenig Anlass schließlich kam
das Gas ununterbrochen aus der Pipeline
als das vorbei war sollten Deutschlands
Speicher sowohl durch Pipeline Gas aus
Norwegen und den Niederlanden gefüllt
werden als auch durch sogenanntes
liquifight natural guess kurz LNG das
über den Seeweg aktuell vor allem aus
den USA nach Europa kommt das Problem
Deutschland hat so lange versäumt dafür
eigene Terminals zu bauen die Terminals
hat man bisher nicht gebaut weil man
sich einseitig auf den ausstream 2 und
damit auf russisches Gas verlassen hat
das ist auch günstiger das muss man
ehrlicherweise sagen Pipeline gebundenes
Gas ist günstiger als das mit
Tankschiffen zu holen bei den Terminals
musste Deutschland dann auf andere
EU-Länder zurückgreifen doch die
brauchten ihre Infrastruktur selbst im
ersten Halbjahr stieg der EU Import für
LNG um 60% gegenüber dem Vorjahr eine
Konsequenz der hohen Nachfrage die
Logistik stießen ihre Grenzen und der
Engpass bei den für den lng-transport
notwendigen Tankschiffen sorgte für
enorme Charterer all das führte zu dem
steigenden Börsenpreis im August 2022
erreichte er seinen Rekord hoch und
stieg zwischenzeitlich umfasst
1000%. jetzt rüstet Deutschland hektisch
nach wir zum Beispiel entschieden und
mit dieser Bedrohung klarzukommen dass
wir an den norddeutschen Küsten
flüssiggast Terminals bauen die erste
Anlegestelle für lng-schiffe ist
eingeweiht zum Jahreswechsel soll dann
auch das erste Gas fließen aktuell
verhandelt Deutschland über LNG Importe
mit Katar den Emiraten und Senegal aber
Mittel- und langfristig bleibt der
Ausbau der erneuerbaren Energien des
absolut entscheidende und unabhängiger
von Importen zu werden und auch daran
arbeitet die Bundesregierung natürlich
absolut zielstrebig eine Alternative für
diesen Winter sind sie allerdings nicht
als hoffnungstechnologie gilt
insbesondere grüner Wasserstoff um damit
fossile Energien in der Wärmeerzeugung
zu ersetzen noch mangelt es aber auch da
an der nötigen Infrastruktur die Kritik
die Bundesregierungen hätten es auch
hier versäumt Anreize für den Ausbau zu
setzen eine Folge des teuren gases im
Jahr 2022 erreichte auch der Strompreis
ein Rekordniveau hinter der Verbindung
von Strom und Gaspreis steckt ein
umstrittener Marktmechanismus die
sogenannte married order die Marit order
das ist der Preismechanismus an der
Börse und der richtet sich nach dem
letzten Kraftwerk was noch benötigt und
zugeschaltet wird von der Strom ist es
heute so das ist oft Gaskraftwerke sind
die die teuersten Kraftwerke sind die
man gerade noch braucht um die Nachfrage
nach Strom zu decken die setzen den
Preis und den bekommt dann alle
Kraftwerksbetreiber das Ziel des married
order Prinzips ist die Betreiber von
Kraftwerken mit günstig herstellbaren
erneuerbaren Energien zu belohnen und
die Produktion zu fördern das ist
nämlich erneuerbare die billigsten sind
und in der berühmten Marit order das
teuerste zuschaltbare Kraftwerk dass die
Versorgungssicherheit bringt den Preis
setzen und daraus ergeben sich die
übergewinne oder Zufall mit dem Geld aus
diesem
als Gewinn sollen jetzt Verbraucherinnen
und Verbraucher entlastet werden bei der
Lösung der Energiekrise steht die
Regierung dabei vor zwei großen
Herausforderungen erstens sie muss eine
langfristige und bezahlbare
Energieversorgung sicherstellen die ohne
Abhängigkeit von Russland auskommt und
zweitens muss sie die spürbaren
finanziellen Folgen der Energiekrise
kurzfristig abfedern dafür einigte sich
die Regierung auf ein Entlastungspaket
in Höhe von 200 Milliarden Euro den
sogenannten abwehrshop keine Familie
keine Rentnerin kein Student und auch
kein Unternehmen soll Angst haben vor
den Preisen für Strom Gas oder Fernwärme
überfordert zu werden ab März 2023 soll
die gaspreisbremse greifen auch beim
Strom werden die Kosten staatlich
reguliert ab Januar sollen die lange
umstrittenen Zufalls Gewinne in die
Finanzierung einer strompreisbremse
einfließen diese Maßnahmen zur
finanziellen Entlastung helfen zwar
kurzfristig und begrenzt durch den
Winter bleibt die Frage nach einer
langfristigen energiepolitischen
Strategie ganz klar ist dass wir aus der
Abhängigkeit in die wir uns in Fragen
der Energie von Russland begeben haben
dass wir aus dieser Abhängigkeit auch
lernen wir brauchen die sogenannten
Erneuerbaren freiheitsenergien wie ich
sie nenne und deren Ausbau könnte durch
die Energiekrise massiv beschleunigt
werden Expertinnen und Experten gehen
davon aus dass der Gaspreis
mittelfristig nicht mehr auf ein vor
Krisen Niveau zurückgeht und wir uns an
ein neues normal der Energiepreise
gewöhnen müssen ein zurück zu den alten
energiezeiten und Preisen dürfte vorbei
sein bei aller Bereitschaft ist viel
Geld in die Hand zu nehmen und die
Preise abzufedern die Notwendigkeit
Energie einzusparen bleibt unvermindert
bestehen und die Herausforderung dürfte
im kommenden Winter sogar noch größer
werden
bis langfristige Lösung wie die
erneuerbaren Energien funktionieren
bleibt einsparen also wohl die
sinnvollste Energiequelle wie ist das
bei ihnen heizen Sie zu Hause weniger um
Energie zu sparen schreiben Sie es mir
gerne in die Kommentare wenn Sie wissen
wollen wie der Gaspreis sich
zusammensetzen empfehle ich Ihnen dieses
Video und hier geht es zu einer weiteren
Folge Kontext abonnieren Sie auch gern
diesen Kanal